yeah welcome to this video here we go
and sunset sue okay okie dokie there
there the Trump yeah usually playing
this line and I've played this guy once
before I'd won the game yeah I don't
have any particularly memory about this
game okay that that's one of them in
many ways home why can can set up
they're usually quite quite solid yeah
go for Bishop d6 next just have a very
sound development whenever the bishop
gets outside of the pawn chain black
really doesn't have much to fear it's
not very exciting though have to admit
some really not much that you can do
them ok so I'm going to take him cannot
be bad um really isn't just just winning
a piece here if I before I don't know
actually that seems to win a piece there
at least one piece yeah so to d6 or
problem yeah I can go to e7 and then go
if for next it's a pin down so no real
problem
white resign yeah that was a very quick
game but yeah probably still worth
uploading if just for this line against
the Trump if you don't know what to do
against the Trump offski 94 is a good
reply and then d 5 it says it's that's
simple but good what black is doing you
just gets this out and if white goes
Bishop b3 which is the most testing move
you just go back that looks a bit weird
an IDF 694 go back but the moves that
right has played in the meantime are not
really that aggressive especially Bishop
d3 as a move that in many lines um
doesn't help him much um it's quite
funny that he actually lost to this this
fork but okayed that wasn't forced and
of course you know this all looks very
very normal cake stakes and if he just
plays h3 now he's okay of course I will
probably just capture and then castle
yeah maybe Bishop t6 it just totally
totally solid and good black has
everything out no problems but it's kind
of a bit of a bland position is not much
going on it's it's equal but it's also
really equal so not not very exciting
there are more exciting ways to play
against a trump but this is what I know
and usually play usually gives me a good
position Yeti after something like that
before I'm winning a whole piece with
this with this fork yeah okay thanks for
watching